we're told that rodrigo watches a
helicopter take off from a platform
the height of the helicopter in meters
above the ground
t minutes after takeoff is modeled
by and we see this function right over
here
rodrigo wants to know when the
helicopter will
land on the ground so pause this video
and see if you can figure that out
all right now let's think about this
together so let's just imagine actually
what the graph of this function
looks like it'll also help us imagine
what's going on with the helicopter
so our horizontal axis this is t
time in minutes
and then our vertical axis is height
so height as a function of time and
maybe i just write it like this
i'll just write height and this is given
in meters above the ground
now i don't know exactly what the graph
looks like but given that i have a
negative coefficient on my quadratic
term
i know that it is a downward opening
parabola like that and it says
that the helicopter takes off of a
platform so however high the platform is
then it takes off and it's going to do
something like this i don't know exactly
what
the graph looks like but probably
something like this
now if they asked us what is the highest
point
of the helicopter and at what time does
it happen
then we'd want to figure out what the
vertex is of this parabola
but that's not what they're asking
they're asking when does a helicopter
land on the ground that's this time
right over here
so if we wanted to find the vertex we
would want to put this into vertex form
but here we want to figure out when does
that function equal zero
we want to find a zero of this quadratic
right over here
so the best way that i can think about
doing it is try to factor it try to set
this thing equal to zero
and then factor it and then see what t
values make that equal to zero so let me
do that
so i say negative three t squared plus
24
t plus 60 remember we care when our
height is equal to zero
equals zero so let's see maybe the first
thing i would do just to simplify
this second degree term a little bit
let's just divide both sides by
negative three if we did that this would
become t
squared 24 divided by negative three is
negative eight
negative eight t sixty divided by
negative three is
negative twenty and then zero divided by
negative three is of course still
zero and now can i think of two numbers
whose product is
negative 20 so they would have to have
different signs in order to get a
negative product
and whose sum is negative eight so let's
see
what about negative 10 and
two that seems to work so i could write
this as
t minus 10 times t
plus 2 is equal to 0. and so in order to
make this entire expression equal to 0
either one of these could be equal to 0
so either t minus 10 is equal to 0
or t plus 2 is equal to 0
and of course on the left here i can add
10 to both sides so either t equals 10
or i could subtract 2 from both sides
here t is equal to negative 2.
so there's two places where the function
is equal to zero
one at time t equals negative two and
one at time
t is equal to ten now we're assuming
we're dealing with positive time here we
don't know what the
helicopter was doing before the takeoff
so we wouldn't really think about this
so what we really care about is that t
is equal to
10 minutes that's when the helicopter is
right over there and actually we know at
t equals zero
these two terms become zero we know it
takes off at 60 meters
it goes up if we put if we figured out
the vertex we would know how high it
went
but then it starts going back down and
in ten minutes after takeoff
it is back at zero back on the ground